Correctly by the central bank 09 and
also to take countermeasures during Corona,
also to start the money printing machine
and set up the programs so that we
avoid uncontrolled unemployment now the problem is only if you
do it once then you have to
lead it back again and it would be naive to believe that
if you lead it back again  that can be
slowed down again very relaxed very slowly with such a development
where you might massively
take out liquidity there are accidents there are crises
and there are surprises and that we
spoke of the proverbial
canary in the mine was exactly
this Canary a chroma that
was the first  accident he is probably
the largest German-speaking dealmaker
no one else makes as many
billions of deals in a normal yes
as the Europe boss of k.k.a Phillip
Freise up, welcome to
the prices Philipp thank you very much for
inviting me that makes me happy
first of all it’s north German that  we
can chat a bit together,
tell me how was your journey
into the private equity world, so you
come from the area around Hamburg, so to speak,
but I've heard that
a lot of siblings don't know it was born, yes,
above all, you have to
yes, imagine that was the way it was back then, it did
n’t even exist yet, so I
grew up there as the son of a father who
was a hotel manager and his mother
was a dentist, so they
both worked, which
was also unusual in the 70s and 80s, but it
was now  Not that people
talked about finances at home
when I thought about what
I'm actually going to do now after
grammar school. You've
always had great degrees  already interested in many things to be
honest and uh and
then when I was finished
I actually wanted to study astrophysics and economics at the TU Berlin
you will now ask why
this is completely crazy but uh you have
physics was interesting for me I
always thought it was cool  the idea of
getting into space travel somehow and so but that
was
a bit too much of a good thing for my entrepreneurial and medical parents
where I said you also have to
do something solid
that was a bit under construction at the time
I was crazy before I was already
enrolled in the  TU Berlin and then
I read an article in the FAZ
that talked about the fact that in
1984 this new
university was founded in Koblenz with the
principle of saying we'll go abroad
year
abroad and you have the right to
do something practically somehow
and so I said that's something
cool, something new in Germany and I applied
there  your
final grade comes in you have to
do another written test
and you also have to do another selection
interview and then I got
in there and to be honest I found the experience
so great because you got to
know each other during this selection process, I was like that  two three
friends from back then and because of the
people i went there and
said okay in space you can
also fly later do
that first and what that did then
you are after that that's a
bit of the classic way that would be uwe
but back then it was before the start-up
scene came to me, so I was really in my
tenth year at the time, that did
n’t really exist that much at that time, so
Olli Samba was a year behind me,
back then, as you correctly
say, there were three
things that you think about  graduated
either you started directly at the
company so Horst Albach
who was my trust in Cent at the time
I really wanted to join AEG
and get that assistant to the board I
also had the offer from Thomas
Mittelhoff to become an assistant
is
you didn’t do that at the time  because my
girlfriend was French at the time said,
guertelslo you're completely
crazy, do it
and well and then you had the choice,
many just gave advice
and what I didn't care about mckins is I
experienced a lot of things there even during my studies
and done so I was 95 in Vienna and
96 in Frankfurt and Micha Medien was always
really interested, so I
worked at McKinsey for ZDF during my internship and since I was involved with the
digitization of television productions,
that was very
early in 1996 and the main reason why I  I
went there it actually
was an option to
get out of Germany because, as I said, a foreign
friend who said I
actually want to fall after four years,
experience something different and so she
made me an offer with my child
to start in New York in 1997 and
then  did you learn there too
and then i left 77 the first
crazy thing was that 98
became mittelhoff zero from bertelmann and moved to new
york so that one of my
clients became and 98 also looked for
kekea in german when they
tried  von Höchst
to buy the Herberts paint division and then
I think I
was sent to Wuppertal in August 90,
no longer known, so to speak, so
it really couldn’t have been more classic
and at that time I really
experienced what private equity actually is, so to speak, in the heart chamber
25 which is
quite exciting because exactly for
bold this Höchststil comes from New York
so what was quite
complex back then okay but then
of course the
newcomony then came the Neuer Markt then
came Thomas Mittelhoff with his
visions which we all know which
were unbelievable back then  and told me
at the time
99 now
stop giving advice and don't do something like that
for your life and if
chapark will now be the new ideal
app in Europe we need someone
to found it, bring it forward
and then have it  practically from one
day to the next in New York
and moved to Berlin
for Thomas Müller for Bertelsmann
is built up, among other things, but also
Goldman Sachs
in
the newconomy time from Berlin
I think it was built up exactly and
you were the founder and the
managing director, so to speak, so Olli Samba was a
year below me. WU
founded Alando in Berlin and we
Venture Park that was the first phase
where  there was a huge sense of optimism in
Berlin, many of the business models
were just not that far,
so if you think about it, Rocket
works now, but
of course we also have completely different technical
possibilities today as an incubator to
pull things up accordingly than
back then, what’s the portfolio
made by you  So I've got something for
managing directors, we've had eight,
I'll give you two examples, one two
Monde Media, it was, people know, I
still do a lot of content today,
yes, that was ultimately
a content producer for shorts back then in 2000,
so what we're doing now  Experiencing YouTube
and so on eisbox.com and so it
was quite well known the other was
Gastro x it was a B2B approach how do
you actually help
gastronomic businesses as I said
my father had a hotel
most hotels don’t have that much
passion  for everything that has to do with processing
POS systems and so
on, back then the idea was
that you would
automate payments, which PayPal then did
and so on, yes, okay, but overall
you can say that the incubator was
not a complete success, well  what
happened as I said the business
is now or then Venture Park is
yes you then have to have the IPO market working
at the end that means my
song investors what Goodman called who
also wanted to go public
then said uh now you have to take a
long time  breathe that's successful
the corporates like beris you
actually wanted to do it that way I had,
I think somehow uh 100 million
was still borrowed at the time and we
somehow still had 90 in the till yes
we opened offices all over Europe
and hired people but  it
was still very young we
somehow did it between January 2000 and July
2001 that means in the end we
came to the conclusion we give
the money back to the investors we sell
these 8 companies for me it was an
amazing experience I mean I was
26 27  28 years old we somehow
hired 70 people, some of whom were 10 to
15 to 20 years older than me and
in the end I had to fire them all,
well, as an entrepreneur, I
mean I have the greatest respect
for every company founder if you
take part in it  got a bit of a
pimple so in the beginning it was a phone
and I was in a small room in New
York and in the end it was like six
offices and so many people and at the end of the
day you had to wind it up again
that was a very formative
experience  for me and then it goes on but
for you then at right I was
then,
funnily enough, training with Julian Deutz, who
is now CFO of Axel Springer, who was
my CEO of venturepark, we were
and Christoph Schneider, Germany's
managing director of Amazon Prime today,
those were the three  Matadors, we
sat together and have now
thought about it, now we're going to
shut it down here together, what are we actually going to do
and all three of them
actually orientated themselves very much towards the
people they either already knew
or who they had gotten to know because
you have to imagine it that way  similar to how we
may have gone through it now with Corona,
imagine that suddenly
everything was closed, the whole Neuer Markt was
suddenly closed, that means you
mainly asked the question where am I doing
something new now that I also have a bit of
sustainability  and for me it was
funnily enough that two of the people
i hired at venturepark
one one in paris and one in madrid
they were
softer the founder was i
turned it on and off in the end
but in the meantime
i have had two people who  went to GPA
and you have to
imagine Kiki but also a startup
is for everyone in Europe 10 people so I
started there that means
I can do two of the ten so it was a complete
coincidence and at the same time I had
experienced a bit as a mckinski consultant what
that  means working for a private app
and then they looked for Germans
three names
came up, so we were
40 people worldwide at the time and one of my
job interviews was actually with
the founders, although uh Kohlberg was already
out there, there was Henry Cravitz and
Georges,
who were in their mid-50s at the time, so in
fact that was of course still very
influential  in the company
and yes that's how I got there in the end
and funnily enough and that's
the crazy thing maybe also as advice to
all listeners
that was totally out no one wanted to
go to private equity and
big mature companies buy old
chemical shops like that or something  everyone
was still very influenced by the
New Yorkonomy to say growth growth
growth and for me it was a
conscious decision to be honest,
so I asked myself very carefully
why was
n't that the success
we could have been at venturepark  At the end of the day,
if you
want to do venture capital then you have to have deep
vertical wants to
know somewhere you have to
be a physicist or chemist or biologist or you
have to be a quantum and if you are a
generalist you are actually much
better positioned to do this privilege
like the business
basically to accompany larger, somewhat established
companies because
at the time before the famous quote
from Franz Müntefering the language
was always about locusts and that’s how it was
afterwards or or still so I was in
the middle of it too that was in 2005 the quote
so I have  already 2001 to 2005 at
GTA Germany also built up so
many of the original transactions
such as from Mannesmann to
buy seven companies that the
Siemens had bought my man
plastic machines and demakrane many of the
original projects that
also led to
us in Germany at some point  So world market leaders became
more flexible for our very industrially strong companies have innovated
and so on and what happened in
2005 in the constituency of Müntefering
was the company Grohe Armatur yes where I
think TPG had implemented a program there
which led to some
in his constituency too  lost in the job
and didn't learn the lesson back then
you have to communicate at the end of the
day and we
also met in many cases when we were in the
very difficult situation you know Germany
had the red lantern in Europe at the time
and only through, so to speak, the in
In 2010 things went forward again,
but we saw Dema Krane, for example.
I saw how we very
consensually looked at it together with IG Metall together with IG Metall and
said
look at us, the prices for
cranes are simply falling here worldwide, here are the
costs  we have to get through this together somehow,
as long as you communicate openly and
transparently, no matter whether they
are employee representatives,
union representatives or
politicians, we have actually
always
gotten along in an amicable partnership, I think that was the
lesson from this whole story,
tell me for a moment, don't really think about
that model  generally from equity so how do
you work from the principle who knows managing
director is already special
so interesting is first of
all I was lucky in that respect as I said I
also got into the startup is
of course that is possible that the industry
invented so what Henry cravis and
George Roberts and her mentorberg
had recognized is that
when you invest in companies
and, above all, make the management the
owner, it was often before the
time that there was a
divergence of ownership and
leadership the principle of private
equity is you become a partner  of
companies
either you buy them whole but in
our case of kikias we are
usually partners so we
still have a family a company
itself or management team as
equity partners in the company
with us in it and then you make sure
you have common plans together
for business you invest
over five to seven years, which is our
normal
holding period, he is very active in the
company, so either
organic or inorganic
growth and in the end you, as a
partner, as a companion, as a transformer, have to
ensure that what you ultimately
create where you help  invest where you
are the owner something will be
bigger international
no matter what you put in I have to do it about three times
that would be good so I'll
say the norm of the industry especially
for larger ones like us is double times
over 5 to 7 years okay and you do
that now with the acquisition
of power, not exclusively with
equity, all with your own
funds, but other means to do so,
that’s right, I think the
industry has changed a lot in
that when we started back in
2001, that’s the principle it was  that
you tried
to leverage your equity investment so you know
the average equity ratio of
German family businesses is
between 20 and 30% and 70% is bank
bank financing that was
very similar in business back then that you
said we do both now in terms of the capital structure
we see in the
last five years the last 10 years
in Germany a trend towards more
equity capital because above all we
finance more growth so on
average we have 40 if I higher
percentage equity ratios now with
our investment but
attractive because if not in the value of
the  If the company doubles or triples,
then your investment is of course
exactly the same again, so the mechanics
have to return this borrowed capital,
of course, but I think what my
own experience is and that is a
very important point if you start right away
is the interest of management
teams
and from property you get the
lever if all of a sudden the Thomas
middelhoffs of the world see themselves as owners
you have a completely different
situation than if they are only employed
managers okay so let's talk about
falling asleep so that means what you so
they so  the first already mentioned what
you so then the now with whom you
have made your name so I
mean you have to anyway because it will
prevail first yes there also
somehow after the deals rate you
as say yes someone who is new to it
come then bring what you bring with you so the the
milestones for you in the early phase
so we actually had three phases
the first phase was the German
phase where we really contributed to the
industrialization to globalization of
Germany there
is certainly something like that again the green dot
or
mqr-  engins but what I
probably stand for today is the
second phase when I
am responsible for technology media investments from
2005 we started with Pro Sieben Sat.1 back then,
which of course was also in a deep crisis at the time,
the global financial crisis
naturally led a television company
where we dealt
with the question of what is actually going to happen
with the traditional media world now
in digitization at an incredibly early stage, the second name
that is certainly well known as just
discussed that it was a
bit my background in
2009 shortly after the financial crisis was
Bertis  Well, the music industry,
which was in absolute free fall, is
actually interesting because
digitization, we tried that together
with Napster at the time, did
n't work, but we then saw
Spotify in the early phase and saw
that there were other business models, so
I wanted to get back into it  into the
right business first of all exactly but they did
n't have the capital and that was
really a groundbreaking
partnership to say we're doing
a partnership now we're doing half
you do half they have the top
1% of the music copyrights they still
had they had the  We sold the rest to Sony
and we
brought in the capital and between
2009 and 2013 we bought the
rights again from the largest independent music publisher,
exactly the staff when we had them who
knew how it worked and
today we can see that
music rights are suddenly worth where every tike
tok real is stored with music and
everywhere tasks have to be paid for
and so we have music rights we just see all the
big artists selling their rights
for a lot of money coming back then
you can say and I remember
a legendary supervisory board
calls 2000 with Thomas Middelhoff and
Siegfried  Luther where the idea was
that I could now also involve employees from
Berti's team Park
who would have been the first division of
where that would have been possible that
hadn't worked out back then, but in
2009 to your point we then got
Hartwig, look for Kai Kraft and  made the rest
of the BMG management team significant
co-owners and it's got a
whole different dynamic too what was there
the value of the film when they got on board
or when they started like yeah well
we
started really really small me  In
total we had a volume
of about one billion, 1100
billion, which we invested to
buy these various publishers together, got
out a few years later,
so I, uh, I think that's
all there is to pay in the Berlet,
they've published them in the meantime  200
million Ibiza and you can
add that to it any way you want,
it's probably
worth 4 billion or so, yes, that's
probably worth it again for you
personally, everyone is actually
involved, I'm trying, above all, to
force and our prince principle  all in all,
being entrepreneurial
means you always participate
in the investments that you
make yourself with your own money, always okay,
that means that's
fun, but a
yes 4x in his short time that can be for you
you grab an order of magnitude
I always try to
understand the start-up entrepreneurs when they
exit what is it because what do
you only have a percent or so here is
a bit more difficult now but how
much money do you have to invest there
initially you can say that  or greater
what invests someone who
is then on the same level as you back
then, so I was still very much a
junior
park, I was um 28 and
got in there, so for me the principle has always been to
be entrepreneurially involved  its
never really just about the money in that
respect yes okay that means it was
n't that much money yes exactly yes
so at the end of the day what
is important again our goal is somehow
to produce 2.5 times over five to
seven  years but that's something that
's average, of course, no, you
might have success stories from where
things are going really well, then you have
other issues where things aren't going so well,
that's always a range, but say
one from the time that was also quite good
yes, we then have the principle of
partnership that you say somehow
we are fitness makers and accelerators and
somehow give ideas also
brought to Switzerland and then shortly
after we enabled beresmann
to buy back BMG again
I pay us to scout24 in Switzerland
together  with ringi-entrepreneurs,
this is actually a very well-
running company, i.e.
real estate and car classifieds
business, which then also prepared us for now,
so Springer,
we got involved and
really managed the transition to mobile
other
business models such as
financial services and so on and
in the end Mobiliar got involved
as an insurance company because at some point they
said what is the
digital world today the best way
to find new insurers is not to
have more branches but if you are
today  in a job advertisements portal
you’re on the way to someone who buys
a car and then they know they
have to be insured they
ultimately bought it from us that was
a very, very successful
transaction that Michael Ringier then
coined this term that’s a win win,
a win  for rings a breeze for
the management team itself and
so we naturally went through
an insane
world financial crisis in
2008/2009 where the advertising industry also
suffered massively we made good
progress at ProSieben we made it
was a successful transaction for
us but not in  of this order of magnitude
like the others we just mentioned
from a while now ten years
later after the deal at that time now
we are talking now in the year 23 I
think it was 21 or something like that you
did ProSieben again all of a sudden so
really just shares there  bought
pretty surprising for everyone and what's
the calculus
so you look at companies like that if you keep
watching them then somehow
thought a few years ago
ProSieben there's more to it so
Philipp you're talking about the absolutely right
topic namely  the permanent look at
what our business model actually is, the
permanent look at people and permanent
companies and ProSieben sind
eins did that very well
to get out of this financial crisis and then
with the whole moment what they had
you can Corona and suddenly the
axis deteriorated massively again
and  our job is
to accompany companies as a partner when it is
most needed and at the time we held
talks to say if things
continue like this here maybe
we can help you again then we
bought the stake at the end of the day
we would have it all from them  Stock
exchange but it was
we all don't know what happened with Corona
the markets
recovered incredibly quickly and then
our assessment was that that was no longer
necessary we did it well
and so we did well, [ __ ] in
case you have  I think in the sense that
you can also do a bit of
math, read your transaction
within a short time is unfortunately
held again, it was or something like 50
million, so
I don't remember the exact number now, but it
was certainly successful, yes,
I mean observing it, but  in the end there
is also an art in general when
investing somehow the
resources are so because the world has
heard it often, you have to
be with the founders earlier if I
sent things you might have been a
founder yourself and children but how is it
in the  pe-welt so how do you get to that
now you talk a lot with
family businesses where so how do you do that
the principle of partnership is very
important we were talking to BMG at the time
we just talked about it somehow
had a transaction volume of one and a half billion but the
most important thing was that the family
Moon has seen what we have
managed to build up together in the
partnership and when
ten years later Ms. Springer
asked herself what
actually is the future of my
company, is it now
listed on the stock exchange or not, of
course the families talk to each other that
was a 10  Billion transaction so
much larger but the principle of
trusting partnership and in
fact as you say that the family
said they can help us or
GFK society for our
research peers because the GFK association
was in the majority we took it off
the stock exchange  because you
need someone who will help you to
manage this whole digitization better as a partner and in all
three transactions GFK Axel Springer and
BMG it was always the relationship with
families or the owners
in it is also recommended that he is a
very important point and on  on the
other hand, what is the most important thing in
our industry, you have to
be among people all the time and also
explain what you are doing, so we
discussed the topic earlier, that means and we
are an insane
generational change, it is also super
exciting what is going on in Germany right now
and once you have experience
how do you help a partner to
become more digital, more global
and how do you specifically help a partner to
go public somehow in the end, then you have a
credibility that helps
you to actually get everyone
You get an appointment and the appointment had to
explain how you
can do that, yes, how was it when it was harder,
I mean, we are very much in Berlin
long before Lars Windhorst came, you
also bought her shares, so to speak,
so you can
Football club don’t buy everything, certainly not
at the club, but if
human society often,
how did you come up with the idea back then, I
think for 60 million, which you only have to
say, what today’s point of view was
much larger, how did you get
football back then  the common thread is
really
content rights the IP long-term rights
we started with music, then
we did film and television,
then we actually saw sport now, in fact, said
that then there was
development at Hertha back then,
for example, there was none at all  Marketing
of the international rights, we
briefly accompanied this during an initial phase and
made good progress there, but
we are now again involved in the overall topic that you invest in long-term rights
with leonalen, i.e. with
mediamanten podcasts, so also because you
then buy with Leon, so to speak, no
production company together with Fred
and and then there were rights again
and now there is a very interesting question
why are we actually doing this because
we are an aging society
because my customers, so if you think about it,
who am I doing this for? They
are
pension funds or foundations
somehow earn pensions
in the long term and they have long-term
obligations we have inflation,
that means the challenge
is we have to somehow produce medium and
long-term results
that are better
than inflation, which means
that we can pay pensions accordingly
long-term rights  So if you
believe that you have the right
music title, for example, you are actually
always protected against inflation and that’s why
this thesis but if harder I mean
harder is difficult in Germany
with all the jurisdiction there is
Bundesliga is absolute you shouldn’t have
said afterwards okay then
go  we prefer to go to Manu like the glases,
or maybe we'll go
back to
Chelsea or something like that, so all in all,
the subject of sports law is very
interesting, I
'd say that was the first
attempt, that worked well
and we will in the future  I'm sure you'll
see other things there,
by the way, there's a very interesting podcast,
Tod Bully, who has taken over Chelsea,
together with the consortium, has
in one, who's actually a guy who
comes from the bond business
in the USA and he's also  a podcast
called die capital
told why he does it too, so he
asks to buy it, argues
the same way, he says somehow, in the end,
sports rights are actually just
another form of bonds, uh,
somehow it’s clearly expected to
be paid for each  year and if
someone drops out of those who
buy directly, then the next one comes immediately,
so you don’t really have any
problems with always looking for the
CEO of BMG who told me about the
boots, so the principle that David Bowie
has his entire catalog Berlin and  said I'm not going to take
a commercial bank but
I'm ultimately going to sell it to a music fans
and their capital, which they have system,
was ultimately secured with the
long-term rights to the
various songs that made that
exactly the principle 25 years ago
and today it's the  Soccer club the
long-running title on women talking we
just got the Oscar
for these things with Media no there, especially in
a world where consumers have more and more
choice and more and more
recognition value must also be there
with rights, which will become more valuable in the long term
but still say
with harder what my girlfriend was out
yes so my job is for my
investors to always get in and out
and I think
timing is important continue to look at it
even after you left as the others
probably wondered a bit
what
happened last year so um  we
talked a little earlier, so
I'm kind of a free time hobbyhorse,
I tend to sit like this and listen to operas
and watch less football, so
I'm less
diplomatic,
okay, but to wrap up the football topic,
you're already
in the  Discussion with the DFL so that
’s the German Football League so
at least there are rumors I do
n’t know how far that’s been publicly
confirmed so it’s being considered
selling the foreign formator of the entire Bundesliga on a project that confirms the question is
which is that  it also what you
look at so you know what you understand
I can of course
not say anything about such concrete projects but logically
that we just discussed
would you make sense to
be there overall such projects
basically make sense yes
think sometimes right now if
well, I'm now
a little deeper into the sport, my
passion, that was like that, think crap, what
the glasses did there, man United,
you should actually have seen that for yourself
and it annoyed you, that's what
happened because that's a great
return they have  recognized very early
somehow you want United you can buy they
saw what will
happen to them in the English Premier League
then they are of great value and
you think I should have done that too
so I’ll say it as a manager and
I’m very European  very optimistic
about all the opportunities that
are still possible here and
you can do so much but
at the end of the day you have to
decide where you focus and
in the entertainment-based
business models you will always
have a lot of competition from all kinds of
investors  who also
proceed in a completely different way than
my industry in terms of evaluation it is
exciting in that respect but you can’t
look backwards we always look ahead
there are so many opportunities
and some do
really classic startups, so I’d say
get yours  guide e.g. but also
Berlin it doesn’t really have such
a great legacy but you were also
quite enthusiastic about it so
Johannes Reck is one of the greatest
startup entrepreneurs I know.
Back in 2015 we launched a separate
growth fund
because we  that's why we observed many of
the large screens that
we had invested in. We've just
called scout24 BMG or ProSiebenSat1,
more and more startups in their area too,
either bought them, you just
mentioned it to
ProSieben, or they did it in competition
and to that extent  we had
all the knowledge but we didn't have
a separate growth form, that means we now have a separate growth fund
and one of the first investments in
this growth form was get your guide
but a few others who are
now so we have
accompanied dark trades there, for example
nobi before yes  So that's
always Europe-wide for you too, so you
kind of always look Europe boss through
the whole continent carefully and yet
you have your both for Germany
sometimes if you think okay better,
so overall completely independent of the
fact that I'm German myself
and also believe in the future of Germany,
Germany is
the most important market for us as an industry as a whole,
first of all, what is the most important
economy but also has
so much to do there I think you have
the
greatest breadth and density of
family businesses here you have an
industrial base the  especially since
Agenda 2010 was world market leader but you
also have the greatest need for
digitization we now have an
energy turnaround and
we have also done a lot overall of course
with globalization
keyword Asia keyword America
but it also has to
change for me  as a kick year
it's always very interesting I come and
speak German I'm there in the room and
you get along, but I also bring
the entire global base with me, so I
bring it along, for example with
Körper in Hamburg we have
40%  bought the division that ultimately
makes supply chain software,
of course they also wanted to make sure that
we were familiar with this, that means my
my partner who
understands the silicon software business is coming
to Hamburg and is now also on the
corresponding team with
the Chinese  chef also there
we are well represented also came along
and is then the one team that means you
bring the entire spectrum
with you globally, but they simply speak
the local language
across all the funds, especially China and the USA,
I think a total of 120 before earlier
companies  worldwide but in the
forest now has exactly how much that
has just don't look at how many
billions you've
invested, so to speak, if you implement that now um
how much investment capital do
we have about 500 billion investment
capital okay what does that mean they don't have
yes  It doesn't work with a form like
a receiver that
can simply call up the money for a fixed fund,
but you still need us
more or less, we have three fixed
private ones, we have our US form, which
is about 20 billion, then
we have it  our Asian fund which
is about 15 billion and we
have a European separate
private equity fund which is about 8
billion and then
on top of that we have infrastructure funds
we have
growth funds like I just said
and also in credit so
actually we're pretty much there  and
real estate is much more broadly
based than it used to be. Knowing that it is
actually a job for you
to run these funds, so to
get the money if I explain all
these billions, they do
n’t come by themselves, you have to
convince investors again  what
you do is a big part of everyday life
absolutely so you have both the
task of communicating what you are
investing what you have invested how it
works so what the vision strategy
is and also maintaining contacts with
the investors absolutely okay that means
they  Resources and what we are doing now
is just as big as money, so to speak, yes
Europe boss in private
Matthias together that means it is also
that is very important to me I'll do
the arc again I just
said as one of the few at the time
that I really had an evening  had a father
and a mother who both
worked as the boss, so to speak,
I have to make sure all the
time that we now
run Kiki, so it
also reflects a modernity that is very important to me and
I spend a lot of my time with it  So
hire the people to lead the people
you recently recruited
Lea Kramer, who is very well-known in the German nation,
also more often in the podcast
regulars um for you or
at least for Weller another
investment of yours how did that come from
such beautiful greetings  with her
this morning
Lea Sophie is a great
entrepreneur we know her from
ProSieben where she also had amorie back then
and for me she stands for what
we just discussed three points
in a partnership so if you in
Germany as a GTA actually do that  Your goal is
to convince others
to own companies with you and to
bring you forward as a personality,
she is very cooperative, the
second is generational change, so
in Germany we have a clear
transition from the 60 70 generation to the
35 to 5 to 50 45 generation
and there it stands for and the third
bullet point, the key word is
definitely modern leadership, which I just
spoke about, it can bring us incredibly
forward again, another leap
because we
know a little bit about your
perspective on Germany at the moment, especially when it comes to Germany Language
Well, I mean there are
a lot of skeptics now, and when I
consume the media in general,
I sometimes get a little
queasy about a lot of things, but
also about Germany’s role in
the world, in particular I
always believed in Germany, so when
I  the late Curonian phase
internally
in that respect I was unbelievable until in the long
run when I remember
the time when in Germany there were also
big question marks
about the future
then we had Agenda 2010
the red lantern became in a few years
suddenly an insane
success story summer fairy
tale world market leader and now we are going
through a difficult phase again a
difficult phase because our
business model is changing the
energy turnaround we also mentioned
our club global global
business model is changing because we
also see major changes in geopolitics
but the basis  from Germany
a knowledge base of excellently
trained people of inventors from
a success base of industries that
also develop creatively
is very very very good
and for me as an investor
this chance to bring these
world market leaders into the modern age as a
partner is extreme  attractive you
always have to look when people say
Germany isn't attractive.
Better go to America or go
to Asia. I'll say
the grass isn't any
greener on the other side either when you
see the competition for something, for example
we do is much higher in
America, so when you see the supply
of equity capital and the
demand is very attractive in Europe in Germany
you have far fewer
investors you have a demand that
is at least as great in intensity and Asia is of course a
very exciting continent but  is also going
through major changes
insofar as Germany has a good
future, I think the
generational change is being reflected
well here, regardless of whether it
is in a corporate world or politically and
we are playing our constructive role
there, then let's now come to the one here
that probably somehow still
known that many others are also
talking about an Axel Springer here in Berlin
somehow Friede
Springer was overwhelmed with it
came the announcement we are now somehow taking it off
the stock exchange and doing it
together with click and then later
more often Matthias who has somehow
become louder in the meantime
tell me a bit from your
point of view why you did it and what you
saw there crazy
what a small world it is in our industry that
at the end of the day not much
talked about the fact that
2000 Venture Park was my CFO Julian
Deutz
that means you know each other you are in
contact you have also seen what we have
achieved together
and I believe that
the question was asked very visionary early on
is the stock exchange really the
right partner for us with
all these changes in digitization
internationalization changed
business models and the question was
asked and we were happy to
agree to the partner  and
yes since then but what have you seen so I mean
at first glance is yes
you can also see another place at
Gruner and yes my old home or
at other beginning it is not a
case when you say okay total nobrand
the thing will be  Now flying, so first of all
we knew Axel Springer, of course,
because we were with Ringier
at scout24 and the core of the business was
the classifieds business, whether
it was StepStone with jobs or whether
it was now
Aviv, meaning siloge and Immowelt
in the real estate sector  we knew
very well from the Swiss
experience, they were also in
very close contact with each other because they
were John venture partners in other areas, so we saw great
potential in these businesses
because these businesses are also in
America through technology investments,
keyword silo  massively
forward real estate platform exactly
three-digit sums into
Springer's business to put it on the same basis
and we knew many people always said
the whole jobs business is not
interesting but we
saw in Switzerland with jobcloud what
an insane
engine that is  was the meta trend that many
have underestimated is this
demographic change that you suddenly
have the baby boomers in Germany who are retiring
and have far fewer skilled workers
that means millions of
jobs are structurally
implemented the logical derivation of this
is the stepson business as so to speak
Problem solver as a technology partner to
tackle this topic in some way,
we saw the potential, I do
n't think the stock market saw it at the time,
thirdly, we also
saw the potential, so we share the
entrepreneurial version of Matthias
Dörfler, that's
an absolute future in digital journalism
So that means,
like we see in America up to now, what he is
doing with politicians and with Business Insider, ultimately
setting up big digital journalistic brands that
have absolutely chances of success and
have supported him with
investments in the billions,
exactly that means you
obviously think you do
n’t have to ask any more questions  Journalism, well, yes,
a digital world, that's what
I do, if in the print world, not so
much, so there is a future for
journalism, without question of
quality journalism
world
always align ourselves with what the
reader or the viewer wants and the
reading and viewer viewer's
habits are changing insofar as
I think when we look at what an
incredible success digital
business models are now having in the
content of the business, it's clear that
the journey into the  Digitality is going, we
support the vision of Matthias
dörfner what exactly the process
looks like now, um, that
had to ask him, it's still
sometimes like that if you're currently
reading SPIEGEL ONLINE or something and then do it from time to time
and then it comes up
Skip the current article  so we
have to move together next crap what's going on
there he knows a lot quite
problematic press I tell
my last year and a half we
know that from ProSieben Sat.1
we were all there
when Sat.1 moved from Berlin to Munich
in the end what counts is the result
and the vision is right
again is a great CEO at work
with his team and we
support that one hundred percent and you
mentioned Franz Müntefering
Silence is
nice but it's not the goal, so to speak, what
is the goal here  to successfully
build companies together and
sometimes there are stutters and then
you are relatively fearless and say that's
easy enough we have to do it
together yes if we
bring about changes that's our job as investors
and the job isn't just to
bring in capital  but our job as a
partner is also to bring change forward
and if you bring this change forward
you have to communicate well you have to explain it but
in a world that is already so
uncertain anyway
changes always lead to fear
that is quite normal and there  we have to
explain well together and through what
are still so that maybe
somehow now with the
Reichelt case it's already unpleasant even
if you have the same English-speaking
company culture as yours, they were
surprised, so you could read about it
in the New York Times, whatever
what happened was that it was
a different moment for you than let's just say the
normal noises so all in all
these phenomena are that you
also need explanations and
also have a bit of noise when there are major changes not
German that's international so
we also have that international so in that respect it
was  we don't see anything
new
in the USA because it's
kind of interesting that
German publishers or
entrepreneurs always come and say we
want to build the largest media group in
the free world here and
some Americans are amazed
at them  about the courage and so
there you don't do anything so it
can work out so what I think is
great about surfing here is a
team player who has the best team so
if you block the people at politiko
or cell phone with knowledge insiders
are there  Yes, people who
also share this vision and who implement it every day. That
means
Matthias is perceived
as a visionary. America, but also as a
team captain, so to speak. You know that's not an
individual opinion
of course it's like that
for you at the moment from exposure
so from the invested money one of the
bigger I mean I think a
total of 9 billion moved for for
the deal is already a lot ne so
from the technology 9 billion was the
total size of the uh that  Transaction which
almost ten of the equity we
invested as a group 2.9 billion
is such a big investment but
you have to keep in mind
since then we have
invested 1.8 billion in the company so whether that
was the politician acquisition or
organic, we were just talking about beef,
we discussed some StepStone,
so we've done an awful lot,
uh, and yes, these are
important investments for that means
one of the things that are current, so
we always have a portfolio to
manage, so if you  Look, we
have, as I just said, in 8
billion funds where we normally
have 15 to 20 investments, that
means on average you have
equity of
500 to 700 million involved in something as
big as Springer, you
always do that with partners
for example, we have our Canadian
friends from cppy in there so that is
an important and large
investment for us is also together with our
partner but in our fund
itself it is now not twice as
big as otherwise it is one of one of
15 then let's just
finish up a few other things
so there's something that was close to your
heart are even closer to you are also
made by you personally so yeah Vantage Tower so these
radio towers that then say out of the
water from Vodafone  I think
the own company was taken out on
the stock exchange, so the
properties of telecommunications that
's a bit clearer calculate
paid for and then you can
somehow sort of do a little bit of
how things work, something else that you think
is very dynamic than I mean  we
just talked about rights i
think what we as germans but also
from europeans can be proud of
is this whole
investment complex in the production
where we said let's start now
we'll bring four german
content companies together i.e. tele münchen
i&u by günther jauch Wiedemann and Berg, who
ultimately made Dark and
Universum Film from RTL and who
then invested in it from the front, have it
in the German market leader, but we have to
be global, then we took a second
step because of Corona, the media
were taken off the stock exchange, so
the French were a typical case
passed a law where they said
25% of the sales of all global
platforms like Amazon Apple and so
on that stream in France have to be
invested in local production companies
and the local production companies are
still allowed to keep the rights
forever, but the price is
down  because of who has a corona that's
my job to say it makes
no sense at all that's yes that's why
I was taken off the stock exchange
Corona that's why we
now have a Franco-German plant
weight and now we recently have
the production company  bought by Brad Pitt
or he
also decided to keep a large part of
the company in equity
that means we now suddenly have
Europeans Americans and
we are proud of it so that
works really well
French
exactly so again the
the  Creating content does
n't matter if it's matthiasdorf who run
the business I'm a swing partner and I'm
trying to continue my interesting
professional life when you think about who
everything shows up on your cell phone and
says somehow philipp has a question
so again I'm
crazy
at the end of the beginning  I've decided
I'm not going to fly to Mars in any way I'm
not concerned with the
wormhole and Einstein's singularity
or something like that, but just do
business like that where I said at the beginning why are
you actually doing it and I think
it's a lot of fun because
what  I also trusted me at the time
because we did
n't become a student there, so it was quite
unusual from the private university that you
also came in there
for the top graduates or
high school graduates who are, so to speak, promoted,
so according to my understanding
you then need the Abi  in the lower
application area ne I don't know what
all of them are but there are all
sorts of CVs from people who um
early somehow
yes
exactly anyway I was asked in this
interview why do
you want to be funded
by the Schönstiftung here now if you are now
just want to do business
and it somehow occurred to me I
said someone has to
do it we have responsibility for
millions of jobs when I
think about whether they are a huge
responsibility if you imagine any normal
family where millions of
children somehow depend on the
responsible  CEOs somehow do
business responsibly yes and
I'm very
motivated in terms of content I'm really happy that I
can really make a contribution every day
somehow bring successful companies up there you
know I've been really disappointed in front of the
CEO and says
man I've got it  also deceived me about the
person who definitely so
um it's not just about her it's all about
our
talent business we have to
get in there but with ten
people at GTA here we are 2500 so it
's crazy to see the growth
and Henry curvy and George
Roberts did that incredibly well,
suddenly building a company that
then became a bit of a magnet for
talent, but at the same time
our job is of course also seen positively in the
companies we look after, bringing in the best
people
it was a huge success  when Thomas Ebeling
came to ProSieben Sat.1 from Novartis and with an
insane innovativeness brought this
company forward with the keyword
digital strategy and so on, so
great,
not everything you do always
works and that is also quite
normal  ok so we're looking at the
current development in the world so
we're talking here
in march a few days after the
famous silicon who is the silicon
valley bank was in weekend then
somehow the question became unclear what happens
with it that's a thing that you
basically it kind of affects so many of
your probably you thank
or knew because their customers
had money yes how did you
experience the weekend so if the profession was
a few days ago but um how did
you look at this whole development
which is incredibly exciting when  you
do it like this and now for as long as I do is
that you suddenly also recognize trends
and I still remember that
moment
when the best nobody wobbled and
then also went under or when
the rescue also took place as a pearl
stone
for the cameras  and said the
savings deposits are definitely
like that and now we're back at this
point
that's to be taken seriously are you
considering that the bank that somehow provided 25
30 percent of the entire global
starter industries with capital was
on the verge of uncontrolled
collapse then that's it for now  to be taken seriously
and we have to ask ourselves what
is actually going on
and if you think about what
happened the following you have had two
big events in the last 15
years first the world financial crisis and
then second Corona where the
central banks said we have to take
countermeasures because we have  learned from the
1930s, as I said, my
father was born in 1921, I
grew up with the entrepreneur father, who
actually always told me in my
childhood how it was
actually possible that we
had all these upheavals in the 1930s, I remember  I am
still very fond of the child that he
once again described to me what
life was like when he was 12 years old
when this world financial crisis and people
were suddenly abandoned unemployment now I will tell you a bit
but the point is the following was correct
by the central bank  09 and also
to take countermeasures during Corona, also to start the money printing machine
and launch the programs so that we
avoid uncontrolled unemployment the problem is only if you
do it once then it has to be
brought back and it would be naïve to believe
if you and that brought it back again that
it would be so relaxed  can be
slowed down again very slowly with such a
development where you take out a massive amount of liquidity there are
accidents there are
crises and there are surprises and
that we were talking about the
proverbial canary in the
mine, this Canary was exactly a
chromain that was the first accident
and that  exploded it
exploded because the American
central bank had to
step in on Sunday and say like Steinberg and
Merkel back then, all savings are
secured because otherwise you could
n't
have avoided the dominoes that the dominoes
fell
what I can tell you is definitely
it will continue  will it crack
in this banking environment or
will it be in other environments where you
suddenly
lead to the
valuation that you have on the
balance sheets, which are actually only
paper valuations, translating into
real liquidity losses if you are real by the train of liquidity
liquidity losses are
produced uncontrollably then it comes to this
it comes to this domino effect to be
taken extremely seriously why we have
then it depends breaks thanks to the
American Secretary of the Treasury in 2009
that the very former
Goldman CEO said very resolutely
I now force every bank there is
no wrong one here  Proudly it doesn't matter whether it
's a group or whether it's Banker for
America or City, everyone is now being
recapitalized with state money
and I've been pulling up this protective shield
since then, but of course we've
had the debate why we have now
saved bankers here with state money and de
facto who  Taxpayers and this
authorization that the President and the
American Secretary of the Treasury had
meanwhile migrated to Congress, which
means that you can no
longer actually say the savings are safe by Otto the Mufti,
you can
communicate it somehow as a
measure of trust, but if that
shakes in the  The banking world is
the congress that has to agree, that's
a big change, people have
n't really understood what that
means, and I think what we have
to take seriously is the following: we're coming
into the mixed situation purely from the completely
technically normal repayment of an
exceptional liquidity  we
had in the market at the same time to a
geopolitical situation where there are changes
between China and America and
the world as a whole is more insecure and
even in our democratic world
we are not in the middle of these elections
we have America were it is
next year and so on  That means you
have a cocktail where so much
can go wrong that I, as a
so-to-say experienced investor,
look at what was the DAX just before
Corona, so if you look at the DAX in
the 19 and now look at the DAX today,
you will find that you are
15  percent
above the level just before Corona,
where I then say to myself, we have
somehow
shut down our economy for two for
two plus years, we are roughly back
to the level we were before, but it has not
grown, yes, and at the same time we are
of course talking about low interest rates  and
print money the markets have
gone up but how sustainable is that
now so my tip to your listeners
I would say
right now it won’t go up that
certainly won’t go up now yes but
it’s a good time for you in the end it’s for me  The following I have done in
the long term so far, my job is
to counteract all the factors of uncertainty with
knowledge, with globality and with people
who have a bit of experience. I
think there are fewer in the market who
have seen the new market crash
who have seen the world financial crisis
who  have seen the euro crisis have
seen the corona if you have experienced these four
crises then you can sleep
easy yes and how
long-term investments are made
the demographic change will not
go away the need for
digitization is greater than ever we
have an energy transition in Germany
and in all of that you need
entrepreneurial
where you usually exactly how long does
it usually take
at least from you see something that
he just told how it was at ProSieben
back then or mind you at the French
company there is
no new change in the law and that's a
pity for  my template so you can get
in there cheaply uh from so you see
something until you act and
then in case of doubt allocate hundreds of millions of
billions so what's the timeline
again that's a very important point that you
just mentioned what happened namely
the change in the law has the company
extremely helpful but the stock market did
n't get it, so it's exactly right
because the quota was in their favor, so to speak, because
now you knew you had to
buy more French content and that was
good films, okay, what Buffet always
says before is completely right, the stock market
is at the end  of the day in an emotional
barometer outside the at the end of the
day it is always either too high
or too
that means and my job is fundamentally
simple to determine where are
the successful companies here now and which
also have a long-term future and if
such a distortion suddenly occurs  then
of course you have the chance
to take action accordingly and to
get started
no, so you first have to get
to know him as a person, as I said, we were already making
partnerships
two years before it
broke at the time, you have to be in constant
contact with people, okay, in
some cases, years of preparation,
yes you  always have a year-long dialogue with
the team with the people in the team you
come up with your ideas you are often
thrown out so you really have to help
a new market that
you have been I do
n't think I've ever been thrown out as often
as back then  in the Neuer Markt
when we were building people’s park, but
once you understand what it
means to
communicate then you’re not
motivated by that, you just keep
saying a few words about other
topics that are, so to speak, the
economy or  The world of the digital economy is
especially busy
then it was almost an hour you did
n't even say it but surprised
actually I was waiting for the
question
but the question is absolutely important we are
talking about crises we are talking
about distortions we are talking about
Europe and Germany the
world map is going under  the fact is we
have insane product
productivity opportunities now via
technology and as we are always later in Europe
than America or Asia
the opportunity is even greater Chat GPT and
Genitive one of the biggest
advances we have seen in many many
years will likely be
just as
comprehensive  bringing us forward like the
iPhone 7 or
Amazon cloud
web service is because it will mean an
incredible simplification of
service processes
that you have a technology to think along with
and where can you benefit a little so how
can you benefit from it than
here yes as a good one  So you
see, this is
an important question for Europe, by the way. Microsoft is
investing
10 to 15 billion in Open alone because
they in turn need so much capital to
buy these Nvidia chips because you
need so much bandwidth to get this
genitive one up front
we have a large infrastructure and
investment business where we also invest in digital
infrastructure, so
we will certainly also participate in that. I
think it is above all a
large-meshed business
where you have to think about where the
application will be
but so many applications in the  There isn't even an area yet, that's
why I had to think ahead for
every industry, how will that change and
what's said about it,
so I believe that there are a lot of
things that you can see right now,
he's like Leia on somewhere in an open
or something like that and they  was going to be eaten
away at some point, so
we don't think we know yet what I'd do
again if I looked at myself
and no one would have seen,
fortunately we thought that
would become Axel Springer's growth engine
but the trend was so strong when the
trend  your friend is um that you
suddenly need a technology solution
to somehow get skilled worker jobs
the same will be the case here too,
for example with all the software
applications that we have as a tool how do you
write your code we see each other above
all what efficient tool too  If you
think about it, there are relatively
huge leaps in production
productivity, even with the
software companies that we
have just written briefly
but a few other things that were also, let
's say, similarly at least hyped
in the media in recent years,
you didn't even flinch
So, for example,
I didn’t notice anything about the whole crypto development now
that you were there,
so I think with crypto and
blockchain you really have to differentiate
between the backing not
so blockchain we have in our
growth fund we have one or the
other investment  also made into the backbone,
so there is definitely potential,
for example, you may have
just seen Circle our our we
were involved in Marshall ways
Marshall races, so to speak, one of the
largest hedge funds in Europe there is
about half of it or just
under half  44% I think that's
the main investor behind Circle
so getting the US dollar which of
course would have had the problem if right
now you've been lucky now
but the principle of getting a US dollar
that you say somehow there is
a principle  towards a digital
currency somehow
that's interesting we as GTA have
n't invested in that now but
indirectly via our heart shape okay but
it's okay but your general say a
few words maybe now if you can understand them on
Meta or Facebook
or do you think you
think  you too, as an
experienced trend reader, okay, surprises
me too, so we
saw during Corona that digitality and
virtuality are the future,
that augmented reality
will stay here, so to speak, and it is also an
investment opportunity, it is clear as
the application is now
I think you have to make a very strong
distinction between industrial applications,
so industrial production in
construction too, that's very, very
exciting, and we had to differentiate
between consumer applications,
so gaming in Bayreuth you
know that I'll be at the opera when
we're going to be on July 25th  For the very first time
in the history of the opera,
having a passive ball there that has augmented reality
is actually quite true, a very brief objection
that the company that has operationally
accepted the share also named it after an
opera character, it was also your
idea, so Traviata is
indeed the name yes  that means you
really sat together as a
couple so he is a great
connoisseur he has just I'm also in
London there I also work there
he also supported us now in Tannhäuser
so absolutely yes you are
really interesting then
really big  Literature and music connoisseurs
a very big culture well that's big that
's of course a one thing that you
share with him yes okay okay uhm so how can
you now so
again I think there
's a solid industrial application I think
consumers also but I would now
personally  say the open ai and
genitive egg the revolutionary
technological innovation is great as now
augmented value
so very important so if
you look at my what can you
do there look at the endpal
or you look at I can join you on
facebook  where they just
said they want to
open up for investors for the first time and we
need more money now because he's under
so much pressure are
interesting companies yes
but you said at the beginning that
you have a high say it's closer to Olli
Samba to her  you have a year under you, he
probably designed the German startups again as a single person with
the most, is there still
an exchange from time to time or
you talk to each other because I think
Rocket has now become a window with people
I've just
sat down with his brother Alexander,
who's also a really great guy,
for example in terms of natural things,
so he also
thinks a lot about fundamental tech. The collector
brothers have done great things for
Germany, so I'm very proud of them,
especially after that  if I
had already put on the wall in the park,
so to speak, that someone then showed
that the business model
could work, yes, but Oliver Sammer
has always been brilliant, I mean, I
thought about it at WHU, where everyone else
went to me or gutmenge, he's
already 98  At the very end we had to
write a practical paper like that,
I think in Siegen it was secular
and
looked at all the business models, so a
long-term visionary yes, but it's
not over for Germany, it's almost a shame
that someone like that
didn't run a company from A to Z, so to speak  a
bit so so now such a large
corporation so Saka Burk-like
to build something himself but rather, so to speak, helped
drive a lot of things a bit, of course, to great
success no question at all
but that's not the one thing
on which he's had his whole life
sat that he would probably be
worth maybe 40 50 billion today
instead of now having shares in
various things that are all
going well but it's not
these transformative companies for
Germany to come out, I mean
Zalando was really transformative for
Germany so if I look at
what  he got everything off the ground
alone, the Rocket principle
brought speed, innovation, and digitality to Germany, and that
's how really great
companies like Zalando
developed, and if you look at what
was missing in Germany,
silicon in particular  Valley is characterized by the fact
that you don't just do one thing as an entrepreneur
and then you're gone,
but above all this ecosystem does
n't exist, so Peter Thiel
or Elon must now do
several things, so Elon doesn't have Tesla
and he  has space ex and he has and and
here the tunnels and there
actually Oli
set the tone in Germany because he
actually did more things
I find super exciting, for example,
that's the nekt of the other
big entrepreneurs in Europe right now  a
health care company also by the way,
you may have seen that I read it
because it was really
assigned to Spotify that
's just the next generation of
entrepreneurship in digitality in
Europe that they say I bring the
skills not just to a company  one but
several and then it will really be yes,
I mean there are also big
doubts that so many people
can really manage to be more or less CEO at the same time
or what
kind of
so these multi-geniuses have so
much potential that I actually  would think it would be a
shame if they only
made one company, what they
have to do is that the team
behind them also carries out the execution accordingly, there
is this one Frenchman who, for
example, was de facto the CEO of Tesla the
whole time, who got me Kinzig from it
I had a great decision and
you always have teams that have
these idea generators and
visionaries or Shell on Facebook back then
with baiserberg or Erik Schmidt who stood
by the google founders
I think that's
the crucial mix that you
have the Schumpeter and entrepreneur  but at the
same time you also have the
best teams who then implement the things
okay that means you believe in
these universal they are but then it’s
almost still about at least currently
you heard little from you
probably more but the
public less than I think
By the way, it's also very nice that
someone doesn't always have to put themselves personally in the
foreground and I think that's why
many have even accused him of
hurting him too much. He does
n't do anything in the background. He's absolutely
visible. He does a lot of things
and yes now
on it together yes and something yes okay okay why
is it actually a private equity
company so that
bears the name why is it you on the
stock exchange yes that is a very, very important
question
because we saw at the time that you
actually have capital in your hands  have to take
to innovate your own company to bring it
forward because
we were only pushing ahead that
means you have
the various funds that
you invest that you make successful as we discussed it
and then you go and put
new ones on what we do  needed is
also start-up capital and what happened
like that was a Buffett who at the
end of the day can set up this principle as the
best that he
has a balance sheet and this balance sheet invests
accordingly in companies and then
we are the biggest
investors today of everything  So what we are doing, for
example, in the 8 billion that I
just raised for Europe,
my company itself has a billion
stake and that was only possible with this
balance sheet. What we did back
then,
ultimately, we went public
and have  through this capital increase,
the company itself sold shares
and this capital then came onto our
balance sheet and
we then started new business with this capital
Everything counts for the global partnership, but now we're
growing, we've
taken in about 700 million, but
200 million of them were from us alone, which means
you first have to take the money into your own hands
to show that you can do it well
and then it's in the second generation
the proportion of what we
do ourselves is lower but you
also do the klimaform, for example, these things
we all start very much with our own
capital market currently
so you have
a company that is um we have 800
million shares I have
n’t looked at the price until today, so 30 billion
30 40 billion on top of that, so if it
were a German company, it would be a DAX
company,
so not several percent, but
suppose, but you have to see, we are
many, we are, we now have over
100 partners, that
is, and we are clearly natural  listed on the
stock exchange so our
company is yes we still have two founders
who
are also involved there accordingly so it is
a sustainable capital base but
again a completely different question because there is also a
name from which the founders are also a
frequent podcast with us  a regular guest
and friend of mine the Philipp Klöckner do
you actually know Philipp
Klöckner is also connected to us yes
exactly with many of our
digital companies by the way that is
a very important point because although we
bring capital we
somehow also bring the internationality
because we just do that  are active all over the world
but then we also bring in the experts,
so take scout24 in Switzerland, for example.
Back then, he also dealt
relatively
intensively with online marketing.
What can we
do better there? That means you’ll have that
before many
Did you already see that you discovered PIP okay, he
knows his stuff quite well, yes, now
I'll send you the topics and then
you'll get reports and then
you'll do exactly that, we
also worked well with the project, for example,
with Florian exactly,
but  invested in visiv funds myself
I don't want that either ne that would
n't fit that's somehow
not ne yes we have a growth fund as i
said our own he makes exactly that one invested in
the late phase
but
how important question how crazy
did i come out of the wc-  world and as
I said, I'll now make the connection to what I said at the
beginning, we said
if you really have to be successful in the toilet world,
you have to
have in-depth vertical specialist knowledge, we're
all-rounders, that's why
we only start with where in the growth phase  we
our job is scaling scaling in
partnership
at the very end one thing that
surprised me too I somehow
have another podcast with thicker there
isn’t that much content about you
either you’re the one back too so
go ahead  thank you very much for
doing it yourself then it came out where do
you want to ask for a book tip
actually I always find book tips
a bit of life because then there are
some more business books that are
then recommended and you
somehow have Magic Mountain so
Thomas Mann  Zauberberg said a book
which I also remember a
huge think how do you come up
so as a formative book on the
magic mountain so the magic mountain was
absolutely formative for me as I said I
grew up as the son of a father
who
also fought the Second World War  witnessed
and who also witnessed this phase of
how a highly civilized society
like Germany
suffered completely in the wrong direction in times of need and phases of crises and upheavals due to wrong leadership and I experienced that very
intensively in the stories and talks
about it  yes the magic mountain especially
the magic mountain is
an extremely important book for us today by the way you
just talked about that it's really
a topic we have an election in
america in a year we have
geopolitical conflicts between china
and among america we have rejection
by revolutionary technology the
lead to millions
of jobs being changed in some way
People in the First World War
banged their bodies and
for me the lets section was always what I
said at the beginning we have to get
involved we have to
try together somehow to
get ahead and make our contribution,
for example
I always have  when Alfred
Herrhausen thought it was great who tried in 87
exactly who tried in 87 the
debt crisis and she said
freedom and responsibility are
Siamese twins that means if you
enjoy the freedom that we
have in Germany today that we have in
Europe today that we have in the
western democratic world
then you also have a responsibility
that you try somehow to
help them
get their jobs, that is prosperity and
security and that it also
communicates and this book is
important to me because I also see my job
as an assignment
there exactly  to do that
critically you have a little bit of the know-how
you can also read about the
FDP closest to you and you get
involved a bit at the end of the day
I've always been more liberal, so what
I found great about the university is
that it's liberally oriented
She was one of the
founders of the university and I trust the people.
By the way, I believe that our
democracy is more convincing and
the better model is because
the sum of many
people who want to somehow realize their own dreams
can come to a more successful result than  if that if the collective
reacts from above my mother
by the way erm got stuck after the war in
East Germany in the already
occupied zone anyway and she
came out to Berlin in '57
studied medicine but younger brother who
was supposed to do it four years later in
September '61  was supposed to start was
suddenly behind the Iron Curtain and
I was also very influenced by that as a young man
we basically drove to the GDR by car
we
went on vacation to Bulgaria to visit my grandmother
there is a deep content
convince things to the father who
experienced National Socialism and to
the mother who experienced the communists
that we are
extremely lucky I am extremely
lucky that I live in the liberal,
western-oriented society and
I am grateful every day for that, rather
in London than in  Germany so that
means because of a woman my my my my my
my first of all it's such
a very good question that in 2001 when the new
Max collapsed, London was the
only standard where you
could actually do something like what I'm doing
now have offices in Frankfurt in
Paris in Madrid in Stockholm totally
international you can also do it in Germany
I am divorced I have four children
I have three daughters and a son by the way
and I am very aware of that
I have the children 50% of the time
so dear people who live because they
American mother is in London,
we also agreed that means I
will stay in London but during the week that
I don't have the children, so I had to
introduce myself. I'm really
in London for a week, it's every day with dinner and
breakfast, so I'm really aware of that
Father, that's also something where I
clearly set the tone at Kik, so
modern management has nothing to do with gender,
modern management has something to do with the
balance between private and professional life
and I manage it myself, I live
it very actively and  the week that
the children are with their mother I travel
I'm in Berlin I'm in Paris
I'm in Stockholm and she also has a
European job no that means you have to
be with the people all the time yes
FDP back because
you're from and  sometimes with Christian
then suddenly slipped into your profession,
so to speak, after politics
is somehow Minister of Finance that's
just in the topic where you could maybe
give him at least a little bit here and there
so I don't know if you
follow me on LinkedIn maybe you've
seen that  I'm in contact with macron
as well as with too naked so Christian
that's our job, yes,
so if you if you do that, that you
somehow support large companies and
invest in Europe, then we had to
offer you as a partner, no matter what
color, it doesn't matter  Whether that's
Angela Merkel Harbeck Lindner or
someone else, I think our job
is simply to be an active part of
society. There are actually
others before or other people
who are doing the same thing from
Germany or someone who
is similar  So from the from the from the from the of the
assets that every manager of
the acceptance or that can do here is
another company that you
meet regularly, I mean GTA
is of course quite
unique in that we invented the industry
and we are absolutely global
and these three funds that you have one
in Europe, one in Asia and one in
America is quite unusual so
if you look at my competition
equity or advent or they all have
global funds and these are the ones that
come up regularly
okay awesome now we actually have
one  made a really big journey somehow
from I don't know Hertha BSC and
football UPS jumped and the birth
already from product equity and at the end of
your life thank you
very much like you do so I definitely
took a lot with me
Philipp thank you very much for
taking the time was  I'm really clear
ciao
[music]